get the most out of Medicare.
Call now.
>> THERE SHOULD BE A
PREPARATION GIVEN TO THE BIDEN
TEAM, SHOULD HE BE THE WINNER,
NOT IF HE’S GOING TO BE THE
WINNER, BUT MAKING SURE HE’S
GOING TO BE PREPARED ON DAY
ONE.
THAT’S WHAT THE TRANSITION
PROCESS SHOULD ALLOW TO HAVE
HAPPEN.
NEIL: THAT WAS ANDY CARD,
PRESIDENT BUSH’S FORMER CHIEF
OF STAFF.
CO-WROTE AN ARTICLE WITH JOHN
PODESTO WHO SERVED WITH BILL
CLINTON SAYING ENOUGH IS
ENOUGH, A SMOOTH TRANSITION FOR
JOE BIDEN FOR NO OTHER REASON
HE SHOULD BE PREPARED JANUARY
20TH AND HAVE PLENTY OF TIME
FOR TRANSITION THAT IS NOT
BEING AFFORDED HIM NOW,
INCLUDING INTELLIGENCE
BRIEFINGS AND THE LIKE THAT ARE
VERY IMPORTANT TO HAVE.
NO DOUBT MY NEXT GUEST AGREES.
JEFF LAKE THE FORMER ARIZONA
SENATOR WHO SUPPORTED JOE BIDEN
IN THIS EFFORT.
SENATOR, THANK YOU FOR DOING
SO.
GOOD TO HAVE YOU ON A SATURDAY.
GOOD TO BE HERE.
>> SENATOR, YOU KNOW, I MEAN,
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS ARE
INCREASINGLY CALLING AT THE
VERY LEAST, NO MATTER WHAT THE
PRESIDENT THINKS OF THIS RACE
AND WHETHER IT WAS FAIR TO HIM,
THAT JOE BIDEN IS OWED THE
INTELLIGENCE BRIEFINGS, THAT
IT’S IMPORTANT, THAT A DELAY IN
GETTING TO THEM BACK IN 2000
WITH THE BUSH-GORE RECOUNT
MIGHT HAVE LEFT US VULNERABLE
TO WHAT HAPPENED EIGHT MONTHS
LATER, OF COURSE ON 9/11.
DO YOU AGREE WITH THAT?
>> I AGREE THAT IT’S IMPORTANT.
I CAN’T SPECULATE AS TO WHETHER
THAT WOULD HAVE MADE A
DIFFERENCE AT 9/11, BUT IT’S
JUST THE RIGHT THING TO DO.
I THINK RESPONSIBLE
ADMINISTRATIONS WILL MAKE SURE
THAT THE RESPONSIBILITY
OUTGOING ADMINISTRATIONS MAKE
SURE THAT THAT HAPPENS.
I HOPE IT DOES AND I EXPECT
THAT IT WILL IN THE COMING
WEEKS.
IT’S BEEN, YOU KNOW, A LONG
HAUL TO GET HERE, BUT I ASSUME
THAT BY NEXT WEEK MOST WILL
AGREE.
NEIL: I KNOW YOU HAD A VERY
TEMPESTUOUS RELATIONSHIP WITH
THE PRESIDENT AND I’M WONDERING
NOW THOUGH HOW HE WILL COMPORT
HIMSELF, IF HIS OPTIONS RUN
OUT.
DO YOU THINK THAT HE WILL
GRACIOUSLY CONCEDE THE ELECTION
TO JOE BIDEN AND WILL ATTEND
THE INAUGURATION OF JOE BIDEN?
>> I DON’T KNOW.
ALL INDICATIONS ARE THAT HE’S
GOING TO RIDE THIS OUT.
I’M NOT SURE WHAT HE’S GOING TO
DO, BUT I THINK THE REST OF US
NEED TO REALIZE THAT THIS NOW
SAYS MORE ABOUT US AND HOW WE
HANDLE IT THAN IT DOES ABOUT
THE PRESIDENT, BUT I CAN’T--
I WOULD THINK BY THE TIME THE
INAUGURATION ROLLS AROUND THAT
HE’LL BE THERE, BUT WHO KNOWS.
WHO KNOWS.
NEIL: I HAD.
SENATOR, INDICATIONS HE’S SORT
OF PAVING THE WAY FOR A 2024
RUN THAT WOULD BE CERTAINLY
HISTORICALLY UNUSUAL.
GROVER CLEVELAND DID THAT AND
ONLY TWO TERM NONCONCURRENT
TERM PRESIDENTS.
I REMEMBER COVERING THAT
ELECTION, BUT - -- NO, JOKING
THERE -- WHAT DO YOU THINK OF
THAT AND THE LIKELIHOOD OF
THAT?
>> YOU KNOW, I DON’T THINK THAT
THE PRESIDENT IS GOING TO HAVE
AN OUT-SIZED INFLUENCE.
HE’LL HAVE AN INFLUENCE GOING
FORWARD, BUT ONCE YOU LOSE THE
TRAPPINGS OF OFFICE AND THE
LEVERS OF POWER AND IN
PARTICULAR TRUMPISM RELIES ON A
CERTAIN AMOUNT OF SWAGGER THAT
YOU LOSE WHEN YOU LOSE AN
ELECTION, AND SO I JUST CAN’T
SEE--
I MEAN, SOME PEOPLE ARE
THINKING THAT HE’S GOING TO BE
THE 900-POUND GORILLA THAT WILL
DETERMINE EVERY SENATE RACE AND
HOUSE RACE IN THE NEXT FOUR
YEARS, I DON’T SEE THAT.
I SEE SOME INFLUENCE, THE FACT
THERE ARE RALLIES AROUND THE
COUNTRY INDICATE THAT, BUT
THAT’S HARD TO MAINTAIN WHEN
YOU LOSE, LIKE I SIDE, THE
TRAPPINGS OF OFFICE AND LEVERS
OF POWER.
NEIL: AND INDEED IN GROVER
CLEVELAND’S CASE HE WON THE
POPULAR VOTE AND HE COULD ARGUE
THAT HE WAS ROBBED IN BATTLING
FOR A THIRD TIME FOR OFFICE.
AND I’M NOT QUOTING YOU HERE,
IN THE PARTY HERE, THAT HE
COULD DECIDE ON ITS NEXT
NOMINEE AND THAT THE TRUMPISM
ISN’T DEAD AND ALL INCLUDING
SHOWING UP AND WATCHING HIM
TODAY TO EXPRESS THE SUPPORT
AND LEGAL FIGHT TO CONTINUE.
WHAT DO YOU MAKE OF THE
INFLUENCE THE SUPPORTERS WILL
HAVE ON THE PARTY?
.
WELL, HE WILL HAVE INFLUENCE,
NO DOUBT.
THE FACT THAT THESE RALLIES ARE
GOING ON.
A LOT OF PEOPLE ATTENDING THEM.
HE HAD A LOT OF SUPPORT, HE GOT
72 MILLION VOTES, BUT HAVING
SAID THAT, YOU KNOW, TRUMPISM,
IT’S MORE OF AN ATTITUDE,
REALLY.
IT’S--
RELIES A LOT ON GRIEVANCE
POLITICS AND DEPENDING WHERE
BOTH OF THE PARTIES THAT ARE
GOVERNING, THAT ARE IN THE
SENATE AND IN THE HOUSE AND IN
THE WHITE HOUSE, DEPENDING HOW
REPUBLICANS AND DEMOCRATS
COMPORT THEMSELVES AND MOVE
FORWARD, IF THEY DO, YOU KNOW,
REACH TOWARDS THE CENTER, THEN
I THINK PEOPLE WILL KIND OF
TIRE OF THE OLD POLITICS THAT
WE EXPERIENCE RIGHT NOW AND
THEY’LL GO MORE BACK TO THEIR
REGULAR LIVES AND SO I THINK
THAT TO SEE POLITICS AS KIND OF
ENTERTAINMENT AS WE’VE SEEN IT
OVER THE PASS LITTLE WHILE,
PARTICULARLY DURING COVID WHEN
SPORTS WERE DOWN FOR A WHILE
AND EVERYTHING ELSE, IT WAS
POLITICS THAT WE ALL TURNED TO,
BUT I THINK THAT WILL FADE.
I HOPE IT DOES.
AS A CONSERVATIVE I WANANT
POLITICS TO BE STEADY AND CIVIL
AND BORING AND THAT WOULD BE
NICE.
NEIL: SENATOR, YOUR NAME HAS
BEEN MENTIONED OFTEN TIMES IN A
POTENTIAL BIDEN CABINET.
WOULD YOU BE INTERESTED IN A
ROLE?
.
I DON’T EXPECT THAT TO HAPPEN,
OBVIOUSLY.
I LOVE THIS COUNTRY.
I WILL SERVE IN WHATEVER WAY I
CAN.
I DON’T EXPECT THAT TO HAPPEN.
NEIL: YOU KNOW THERE HAVE BEEN
PRECEDENCE, CHUCK HAGEL FOR ONE
WITH PRESIDENT OBAMA SO IT’S
NOT UNTHINKABLE.
>> IT HAPPENS MORE OFTEN THAN
NOT.
WHETHER I WOULD BE CHOSEN,
THAT’S WHAT I QUESTION.
NEIL: SENATOR FLAKE, THANK YOU